Hello and welcome. I'm James Murphy.
In thisvideo, we're talking about multiple assignments or chained assignments in Python.
These multipleassignments are different than tuple assignments.
Multiple assignments involve multiple equal signs
not multiple things on the side of the equal sign.
But they can be combined.
By the end of this video,I hope that you're going to understand multiple assignments well enough
that you can understandsomething like this extremely tricky example.
But before I get into the explanations ofthings, let's talk about this video's sponsor.
Me.
That's right, me. I'm sponsoring my ownvideo.
Did you know that I am available for software contracting, consulting, training andinterview prep services?
So, if you're looking for someone to do a code review or help youhunt down a bug, please consider using me.
Okay, let's get back to multiple assignments.
If Igo ahead and run this code,
of course, we see that four copies of the empty list are printed out.
Butare these the same copy of the empty list or are they different copies of the empty list?
So, if Iprint out a is b, do you think this is going to be true or false?
Let's run it again and we see thatthe answer is True.
So, these are in fact all just different names for the same copy of the emptylist.
They're not all different empty lists.
This is slightly different than what you would have if youdid a tuple unpacking.
If you said, like, a, b = [ ], [ ],
then these twoempty lists on the right hand side are different.
So, a and b will be pointing to different things.
So, when I run it this time, I see False at the end because these two empty lists are different.
What'shappening here is analogous to the following.
First, we evaluate the right hand side and storeit in a temporary variable.
Then we go from left to right
and assign each of the things equalto the temporary variable one after the other.
When we write it this way, it's clear that they'reall going to be both equal
but also identical in the sense that a is b will be True.
Thinking aboutit this way is really going to help us understand this trickier example.
For starters, let's goahead and print out what we get in this example.
If you'd like a moment to think about it foryourself before I explain, pause the video now.
And make sure that you're able toexplain why this [...] appeared
Okay, here's how you're supposed to reason aboutthis code.
First off, we make a temporary variable and set it equal to the right hand side.
Thenwe go from left to right.
And we do each of the assignments one after another.
So, I'll say a commab equals tmp and then a slice equals tmp.
After this assignment, we have that a is equal to thislist containing the empty list
and b is equal to this empty list.
So, in particular, after this line,a is a list.
Since a is a list after the previous line, it makes sense to use this expression.
So, whatthis does is, it assigns the contents of a equal to the right hand side.
So, the contents of a willbecome equal to the contents of this tuple.
Meaning that, a will now contain these two elements.
But remember, before this line, a was equal to this element.
So, then when we're setting its contentsto be these two elements,
we're setting a to be one of the members of itself.
that's where the [...] come in.
When you print out a recursive cyclic data structure like that,
Python will notice thatthere's a cycle.
And then just print [...]
And that's your cue to think: Oh, I have acyclic reference in there.
So, let's go ahead and print it out again and see what we have.
So, westarted with a equal to this and b equal to this.
And then we replace the contents of a with thisand this, which are a and b.
So, you can see here, the highlighted blue portion. That's the contents of a.
So, a contains a and b. That's why we have these [...] here.
It can't just print out all of a. Becauseof the cyclic reference, it would go on forever.
We can confirm our intuition by printing outa is a[0].
Since this is going to be true
that shows us that the first element of a is a,
confirming that we have this cyclic reference.
Okay, I admit that example was kind of silly.
Youreally shouldn't ever be writing code like this.
I think a good rule of thumb is that
for anyvariable like a, you shouldn't use it in more than one part of a multiple assignment.
Otherwise, you'rejust asking to confuse people.
So, yeah. You might be able to use this to trick your friends or whatever.
But in real code, please don't ever do this.
But I think it is important to understandthe way that multiple assignments work.
Namely that, you first evaluate the right hand sideand then go left to right assigning things in turn.
So, this is really the example that you should keepin mind.
If the only language you're familiar with is Python, this might not be confusing at all.
Buta lot of you I know do know more than one language.
And you might actually be confused by this becausea lot of languages do it a slightly different way.
One big difference about Python is that:
InPython, an assignment is not an expression, it's a statement.
The difference here being thatsomething like d equals the empty string doesn't return anything.
It doesn't have a value.
It justassigns the right hand side to the left hand side.
But in a lot of other languages, assignments arealso expressions.
So, the assignment d equals empty list would return d back to you.
But Python doeshave assignment expressions. They were added in 3.8.
They use this colon equal syntax.
And it doesessentially the same thing that the equals does with some restrictions about where you can use it.
But it also returns the value back to you.
So, this d := 0 is going to return that zeroback to me
which I then assign to c and then to b and then to a.
And when you write it this way,
itbecomes clear that the only way that this could make sense is if you do things right to left, notleft to right.
I have to start on the right hand side here.
Otherwise, the parentheses can't makesense.
Because I couldn't start on the left with a equals b, because b isn't defined yet.
I haveto start right to left.
So, that's going to be the big difference between Python and other languages.
In Python, the normal equals operator is going to go left to right.
But in many other languages andin Python if you're using assignment expressions,
then it actually goes right to left.
And if you'rewondering about all the redundant parentheses here, they're there because they have to be.
You're notallowed to chain multiple assignment expressions together unless you put them in parentheses.
Python does this to discourage people from using assignment expressions
where they reallyshould be using just regular old equal sign.
Okay, quiz time. Let's see if you really understandthe rules.
What does this function print if you were to call it?
Put your answers in the commentsbelow.
And that's all I've got for now. Thanks for watching.
And thank you to my patrons and donorsfor supporting me. I really appreciate the support.
If you especially like my videos, pleaseconsider becoming a patron or donor.
And subscribing to the channel, liking the video,commenting, all that good stuff.
Thanks again.